pierre lévy merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation directe ur rt france alors
depuis ce matin on le disait sur le
réseau twitter
on lit que votre compte est affiliée à 1
et à la russie on le rappelle vous ne
recevez aucun financement étranger vous
n'êtes pas relier un service public
russe
alors comment twitter a justifié cette
démarche comment est-ce que vous la
comprenez
alors d'emblée il faut rappeler confirmé
qu évidemment cette affirmation est une
contre vérité flagrante risible et
inventée de toutes pièces alors moi j
ignore à ce stade comment twitter a
justifié où trouver cette fausse
information en tout cas d'un côté on ne
sait s'il faut en rire ou en pleurer
d'un côté évidemment il s'agit d'un
mensonge pur et simple de l'autre c'est
un coup de pub bien involontaire que
twitter nous donne puisque nos lecteurs
savent bien que notre mensuel un mensuel
progressiste radicalement recrue tic est
un mensuel indépendant et si le souci
depuis une vingtaine d'années puisque ça
fait 20 ans qu'on existe avant sous le
titre bastille république nations avec
cette curieuse d'étiquettes et bien la
curiosité et de l'indignation s'est fait
jour et celle a provoqué de nombreux
abonnements sur notre site ainsi que au
mensuel donc nous en réjouissons mais ça
ne nous empêche pas d'être extrêmement
mal à l'aise sur ce type d'affirmation
alors vous publiez un ce lundi un
article très complet sur le russe yagg
est pour rappel un c'est la thèse dont
le coeur était la présumée existence
d'une collusion entre moscou et l'équipe
de donald trump pour favoriser
l'élection de celui-ci
alors avant de revenir sur cet article
pensez vous qu'il pourrait y avoir un
lien entre sa publication et le fait que
twitter vous affilier à la russie eh
bien écoutez c'est en effet une bonne
question j'aurais dû commencer par cette
part là nous n'avons évidemment aucune
preuve de ça mais le fait est que la
coïncidence est troublante puisque le à
la minute même où dans les minutes qui
ont suivi la publication de cette
importante article très documenté très
bien fait signer par notre collaborateur
de l'équipe du journal laurent doré et
que je conseille vivement à la foulée à
tous les internautes
elle le fait est qu'il y a eu quelques
minutes à peine entre le moment où cet
article a été mise en ligne et le
la labellisation en quelque sorte par
twitter on peut donc se poser
légitimement des questions dans un
climat évidemment où tout ce qui peut
parce que évidemment certains nous ont
dit mais c'est plutôt un compliment
qu'on vous fait d'être affiliées à
l'état russe de manière ironique en
quelque sorte en même temps tout ça
s'inscrit dans un contexte politique où
la russie est en quelque sorte montré du
doigt toujours le mouton noir de plus en
plus ça fait différentes affaires et
donc probablement ce type d'affirmation
n'est pas particulièrement bienveillants
en tout cas oui le lien avec cet article
est une hypothèse sachant d'autre part
que notre journal note mensuelle qui eux
donnent les informations critiques sur
l'union européenne mais qui par exemple
dans son prochain sommet reparlera du
cadre financier qui est qui a fait
l'objet d'affrontements et d'un accord
ce mois de juillet qui parlera aussi du
plan de relance qui parle de la
biélorussie qui parle de la turquie bref
nous donnons des informations des
analyses qu'on ne trouve nulle part
ailleurs et peut-être ça dérange et
peut-être certains essayent de careca
virtuel en tout cas nous nous cherchons
injuste mais nous garderons notre
indépendance quoi qu'il arrive justement
votre analyse
dans cet article vous publiez votre
analyse concernant 56 médias de premier
plan
vous parlez d'un conspirationnisme même
stream avec comme ressort la détestation
de la dîmière poutine et la détestation
de donald trump
expliquez-nous qu'elle fait ils font
écrire cette conclusion finalement
mais ce que ce que notre note laurent
doré à juste titre c'est 98% de la
presse française a repris sans les
contrôles et un certain nombre
d'affirmations de tenants de la thèse au
chalet de la collusion supposée entre
vladimir poutine et donald trump sans la
vérifier et surtout quand cette thèse a
été mise en pièces si je puis dire par
les différents rapports différents étude
américaine
les journalistes beaucoup de journalisme
steam françaises se sont abstenus de
reconnaître leurs erreurs ou en tout cas
de revenir sur cette affaire certains
considèrent même que la collusion et
toujours avérée alors qu'il n'y en ait
que que ce n'est nullement le cas mais
au fond on n'en est pas à une
approximation près puisque vous le sujet
précédent vous parliez du brésil
voilà encore notre journal a largement
informés a toujours considéré que le
brésil se ferait c'est chose faite
aujourd'hui des négociations sont en
cours et le continent informer nos
lecteurs et je renvoie évidemment tout
ne les corps et tous ceux qui vont le
devenir à nos articles sur la question
donc oui sans doute
ce contexte là explique pour une large
part cette
ce malentendu je mets des guillemets
bien sûr mon malentendu avec avec son
réseau social que nous regrettons mais
qui finalement nous fait une publicité
que nous n'attendions pas peut-être pour
conclure en quelques secondes
est ce qu'il existe une russophobie de
la part de de certains journalistes qui
sont ces médias visés comment est ce que
vous expliquez riez cette prétendue
russophobie
alors évidemment quelques secondes c'est
un peu complexe d'expliquer la hausse au
1er en tout cas le fait à qui il s'agit
bien pour une large partie de la presse
dominante et pour la classe oligarchique
dominante d'une constante et qui ne date
pas d'hier et qui n'est pas
spécifiquement française qui est le fait
aussi de l'union européenne
probablement et s'est pas forcé c'est
pas pour dire du bien spécialement ma
russie mais probablement ça sert des
intérêts d'avoir en quelque sorte un
diable à sa porte ou en tout cas pas
loin et par ailleurs la volonté de la
russie par ailleurs de la chine de ne
pas accepter un nouvel ordre mondial
dominé par les puissances impérialistes
joue sans doute un rôle à cet égard
enfin chacun a les éléments et peut
faire son analyse à ce sujet en tout cas
je ne sais pas s'il a pris mais si
vladimir poutine a vu cette nouvelle y
serait sans doute fier de savoir qu'il a
sous sa coupe
un média supplémentaire en l'occurrence
structure mais évidemment il ne s'agit
pas de la réalité la réalité c'est que
nous continuerons informé comme nous le
faisons jusqu'à présent à proposer nos
alliés nos analyses et ce de manière
indépendante
merci beaucoup pierre lévy d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le rédacteur en chef du
magazine rupture